bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la démocratie version
marine le pen ou emmanuel macron les
deux finalistes martel leurs
propositions phare pour sortir de la
défiance les deux vols consulter
davantage le peuple mais pas de la même
façon révolution référendaire pour la
candidate du rassemblement national
grand débat permanent pour le candidat
en marche on passe au crible de ce soir
leurs propositions pour revivifier
l'exercice démocratique avec nos invités
dans un instant sur ce plateau notre
grand témoin et philosophe fait lui
aussi s'inquiète de la grande fatigue
démocratique du pays public aujourd'hui
une lettre ouverte dans libération
lettre ouverte à la jeunesse tentés par
l'abstention et sans lui donner de leçon
il tente de la convaincre d'éviter le
pire d'abord quitte à descendre dans la
rue après le philosophe marc crépon est
avec nous ce soir enfin dans leurs
cannes ce soir la sémiologue mariette
darrigrand va passer au crible de le
vote des femmes au premier tour et puis
la vie de black ausculte ce soir des
échanges pour le moins rugueux entre le
président candidat elle français en
terrain hostile et voilà pour mener ce
soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs l'abstention massive du
premier tour a fini par installer la
question démocratique au coeur des
programmes des deux finalistes et il
faut plutôt s'en réjouir conférence de
presse de marine le pen est fière
nouvelle proposition dégainer dans cet
entre-deux-tours par emmanuel macron qui
des deux est le plus à même à
réconcilier les français avec un système
démocratique à bout de souffle de
bonsoir patrick mignola et bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous présidez le groupe modem
à l'assemblée nationale député de savoie
sortant et grand défenseur de la
proportionnelle cher à françois bayrou
bonsoir julien audy bienvenue vous êtes
le porte parole du rassemblement
national jean philippe desrosiers
bonsoir a besoin cette
constitutionnaliste professeur de droit
public à l'université de lille et
bonsoir thomas legrand bonsoir ravi de
vous retrouver éditorialiste politique à
france inter et chroniqueur dans cette
émission alors on va commencer par ce
que propose marine le pen on verra
ensuite emmanuel macron dans un deuxième
temps de la candidate du rassemblement
national propose ce qu'elle appelle donc
une révolution référendaire explications
avec marc au poignet une révolution
référendaire dans le prochain
quinquennat c'est ce que souhaite marine
le pen pour améliorer le fonctionnement
démocratique
à partir du moment où les français le
peuple français veut se saisir d'un
sujet qui peut être un sujet de société
eh bien il se réunit cinq cent mille
signatures et cela déclenche un
référendum nous n'avons pas peur du
peuple nous souhaitons rendre le pouvoir
au peuple dans son programme marine le
pen propose de consulter les français
pour introduire une dose de
proportionnelle à l'assemblée nationale
mettre en place un septennat non
renouvelable instaurer leur hic le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
instaurée aussi la préférence nationale
pour les logements sociaux par exemple
il ne s'agit pas d'interdire aux
étrangers de pouvoir accéder au logement
social il s'agit de donner une priorité
aux français c'est à dire que s'il y a
des logements sociaux qui sont
disponibles et bien on sait exactement
des projets qui se heurtent
potentiellement à la constitution
l'article 89 prévoit qu'une proposition
modifiant notre texte suprême doit
d'abord être adopté par les députés et
les sénateurs avant d'être soumis à
l'ensemble des électeurs le projet ou la
proposition de révision doit être voté
par les deux assemblées en termes
identiques un argument repris par
emmanuel macron le président-candidat
accuse marine le pen de ne pas respecter
notre cadre constitutionnel
quand madame le pen dit moi je
changerais notre constitution sans en
respecter les règles c'est à dire en
disant au fond je vais aller pas voir
référendum même si la constitution
l'interdît
folie folie
marine le pen elle se défend le seul
souverain en france c'est le peuple le
seul souverain c'est le peuple si le
peuple français choisit de changer sa
constitution alors il le fera en 2000 le
conseil constitutionnel a jugé que le
recours au référendum modifiant la
constitution sans passer par le
parlement était un abus de pouvoir
on va évidemment commencer par vous
redonner le pouvoir au peuple à travers
le référendum on entend marine le pen
elle est avocate me connaît bien le
droit constitutionnel
on ne peut pas changer notre
constitution par référendum direct alors
pourquoi s'acharner sur cette mesure là
la priorité nationale révision
constitutionnelle pour pouvoir ensuite
l'adopter par référendum ça n'est pas
possible puisqu'elle n'a pas le
parlement et pas le sénat même si elle
est élue le 24 avril prochain vous
verrez que ça va bien se passer déjà
d'une et vous verrez que ce sera
possible déjà 2 c'est vrai que on a
l'impression à entendre certains
commentateurs et puis nous adversaires
là ma chronique que rien ne sera
possible que l'europe fera barrage que
le conseil constitutionnel empêchera
tout que même marine le pen n'aura même
pas de majorité parlementaire un mois
après son élection à la présidence de la
république marine le pen souhaite rendre
le pouvoir et la parole au peuple
français ce pouvoir et cette parole ont
disparu finalement puisque depuis 2005
nous n'avons plus de référendum terre
que le peuple français n'a jamais été
consultée depuis 2005 autrement que par
les élections évidemment je pense que
pour renouer le fil démocratique entre
nos institutions entre la décision
politique entre la chose publique et nos
concitoyens qui s'en sont éloignés
malheureusement on l'a déploré élection
après élection il faut se rappeler
l'abstention terrifiante aux dernières
élections régionales et départementales
je pense qu'il faut le référendum à la
fois d'initiative citoyenne lerrick donc
pour que cinq cent mille signatures
puisse déclencher à à faire avant par
les à prioris est parti puis et puis
ensuite mais j'ai ensuite compte jamais
voulu dire à moins que la priorité
nationale c'est la mesure phare c'est
l'une des mesures comme l une des
mesures phare a effectivement qui j'ai
demandé de la constitution tiens on va y
revenir parce qu'on va essayer de
comprendre comment elle peut y parvenir
parce qu'il existe une constitution à
moins de la changer de fond en comble et
de faire une sixième république une
constituante comme jean luc mélenchon
faisait des médias jean philippe
desrosiers est ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler ce qu'il est possible de faire
ou de ne pas faire en matière de
référendum pour un président de la
république on a préparé deux panneaux
article11 article 89
je ne sais pas s'il est utile de le
rappeler je le ferai je vais le faire
très volontiers mais lorsque j'entends
les propos temps de madame le pen qui se
targue de bien connaître le droit
constitutionnel que de monsieur odoul
qui nous dit que ça va être possible et
ça se fera à quoi bon rappeler les
règles constitutionnelles puisque en
disant cela madame le pen s'élève
s'érige en terroriste de démocrature
préparant un coup d'état constitutionnel
c'est à dire que il y a des règles il ya
des règles des règles de droit que nous
devons respecter il arrive que des gens
ne les respecte pas et assume de violer
ces règles de droit les terroristes ne
respectent pas les règles de droit et
assume de violer les règles de droit et
on peut leur rappeler la règle mais je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
véritablement utile alors puisque
effectivement une autre où mme d'antenne
qu'avec les terroristes fait agréable
puisque vous demander
puisque vous demander quelles sont les
règles sur le référendum pour pouvoir
effectivement les contourner je ne vois
pas d'autres comparaisons possibles mais
le référendum effectivement est ouverte
voit dans la constitution la voix de
l'article 89 qui est spécifique pour la
révision constitutionnelle et qui
suppose ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure
au préalable que le parlement
s'accordent sur le texte qui va être
soumis à référendum c'est à dire que
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
doivent adopter un texte et ce n'est
qu'après que le texte peut être soumis
rénale inscrire dans la constitution lui
ment donc si on souhaite inscrire
l'action souhaite inscrire la préférence
nationale ou la priorité nationale dans
la constitution il faut au préalable que
le parlement l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat adopte un texte identique tous les
deux et ensuite on peut le soumettre à
référendum si on passe par une autre
voie celle de l'article 11 qui est
l'autre voie pour faire un référendum
alors c'est aussi possible mais ce n'est
pas possible en matière
constitutionnelle ce n'est possible que
dans les matières qui sont prévues par
cet article 11 qui exclut la matière
constitutionnelle et qui ne leur servent
que à l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics pour ce qui relève de la loi et
à la politique économique social et
environnemental de la rente alors vous
avez consacré un édito ce matin à ce
sujet thomas legrand il ya des
précédents tout de même vous citiez
d'ailleurs général de gaulle c'est en
1962 et demande au peuple d'élire si
vous si oui ou non il est d'accord pour
élire le président au suffrage universel
et ça ça bouleverse la constituent bien
sûr et c'est sur ce précédent que marine
le pen bas peut-être à juste titre ceux
se base puisque finalement le général de
gaulle qui a écrit la constitution
la changer en 1962 en passant par
l'article 11 il se trouve qu'à l'époque
tous les professeurs de droit tous les
constitutionnalistes le conseil d'état
plus le conseil constitionnel dont son
président nommé par le général de gaulle
ont dit non ça c'est c'est pas une bonne
voie mais il est passé il est passé
quand même et la révision c'était de
faire adopter le principe de l'élection
du président de la république au
suffrage universel direct en 62 ça a été
adopté et évidemment ça a été adopté
donc là vous pouvez marquer un point
c'est à dire à partir où le peuple a
jugé le peuple à voter tous les juristes
doivent rentrer chez eux il se trouve
qu'à l'époque en 1962 d'abord c'était un
référendum pour ouvrir un droit pour
augmenter un droit
un droit de plus en plus c'était un
référendum
plébiscitaire le général de gaulle avait
dit que s'il le perd des ils
démissionneraient
mais ça n'en fait pas ça n'en fait c'est
pas parce que ces deux bonnes années
et depuis eh bien les choses ont évolué
c'est à dire que on refuse les
référendum publicitaire il
se trouve que la marine le pen ne veut
pas ouvrir un doigt l'endroit mais veut
le refermer et surtout et surtout depuis
le conseil constitutionnel a évolué
c'est à dire la droite et la gauche et
le conseil constitutionnel avec sa
jurisprudence
n'ont évolué c'est à dire ce n'est plus
un conseil le général de gaulle voulait
que ce soir un concert en fait je
voulais que ça soit la maison de
retraite de rené coty et et petit à
petit c'est devenu une juridiction et ça
l'est devenu ah ah après deux étapes je
parle sous le contrôle d'un professeur
droit conditionnel il ya un moment le
conseil constitutionnel a décidé qu'il
le jugerait de la légalité des lois en
fonction non pas de la seule
constitution du seul texte du bloc
constitutionnel c'est-à-dire aussi avec
le préambule qui contient la déclaration
des droits de l'homme ce qui peut poser
problème la marine le pen et mais il
faut assumer de que d'avoir un problème
avec la déclaration il est important ce
débat
alors je finis juste et il ya eu 1 1
une jurisprudence en 2000 qui a vous
l'avez rappelé qui dit que maintenant le
conseil constitutionnel est saisi ce
peut se saisir enfin sur recours mais en
tout cas peut juger de la légalité ou
pas d'un décret de convocation du
référendum c'est à dire si c'est pour
changer la constitution et le conseil
constitutionnel va dire non pas
l'article 11 l'article 89 comme vous
nous l'avez rappelé pourquoi c'est
important parce longueur est important
parce que ce texte hérité du
scion par par référendum marine le pen
pourrait faire tout ce qu'elle veut mais
en respectant les règles il ya des
règles la droite ne veut pas le faire
parce qu'elle n'a pas la majorité dans
une des chambres et elle ne leur a pas
avant un bout de temps dans une et le
sénat qui est à bien l'attendre
jory t mais enfin quand on n'a pas la
majorité dans une des chambres et ça ça
motive de choisir une voie qui n'est pas
légal
ça commence à faire peur quand le
lendemain elle dit elle dit en même
temps bah vous vous n'êtes pas
journaliste pour moi c'est aux
journalistes de choisir qui est
journaliste pas aux gens qui là on
commence
je parle pas de terroristes parlerais
plutôt d'une organisation voilà le
modèle urban qui d'ailleurs sont son
meilleur ami en europe président
hongrois riehl libéralisme comme disent
les patrick patrick mignola c'est
important parce que des gens qui nous
regardent ils se disent au fond est ce
que c'est normal ce ce filtre
parlementaire est ce que le peuple
souverain ne doit pas avoir le dernier
mot il est important ce débat là vous
allez nous dire au fond quelle est la
religion des mitaines macro mater de
référendum mais d'abord sur ce débat là
c'est un débat très important parce
qu'au fond je suis d'accord c'est le
peuple doit toujours avoir le dernier
mot il faudra probablement qu'on utilise
plus le référendum dans le dans les
années et les décennies qui viennent
vous savez il ya quelque chose qui
compte beaucoup c'est l'exemplarité des
politiques et si quand on veut modifier
la loi et quand on veut modifier la
constitution on commence par violer la
loi et par violer la constitution
surtout si c'est en début de mandat
parce que si j'ai bien compris après
l'élection de marine le pen serait
sharon hom viendrait très vite je pense
que ça va être très difficile ensuite
d'organiser
l'état de façon apaisée et d' expliquer
des petits délinquants qui peuvent
embêter tout le monde et j'avais compris
que le rassemblement national avec dans
ses objectifs le fait de lutter contre
la délinquance ça va être difficile
d'expliquer à quelqu'un qui vole un vélo
qu'il faut pas enfreindre la loi alors
que la présidente de la république vient
de le faire la réponse vient au 12 mai
mais sur le fond mais sur le fond cette
constitution là parce qu'elle est écrite
avec ces garde-fous parlementaire c'est
une bonne chose mais le met évidemment
que c'est une bonne chose d'avoir un
texte commun qui permet de trouver un
espace apaisé et en fait j'entends ce
que monsieur oudoul dit est ce que
marine le pen dit sur le
sureau fond le peuple contre le
parlement et le référendum contre le
parlement et je crois que c'est une
erreur fondamentale dans le
fonctionnement démocratique certes moi
je suis pas pour le grand emplacement du
parlement par le référendum
il me semble quand même que on a besoin
aujourd'hui de beaucoup plus souvent de
redonner la parole au peuple ça peut
être par le référendum ça peut être
parler convention citoyenne comme on a
fait ensemble dans ce mandat ça peut
être par la démocratie participative et
sont le fait vivre sur le terrain dans
les communes on peut développer du
référendum d'initiative locale en fait
on peut faire de la démocratie
participative parce que les gens peuvent
effectivement plus supporté qu'on
al'impression de signer un chèque en
blanc un président ou une présidente de
la république à des parlementaires
pendant cinq ans et qu'ensuite on
revienne pas les voir alors quand on est
sur le terrain ils viennent nous voir
nous tire la manche et nous engueule
alors
je pense c'est très important si vous
avez vraiment cette ambition de
réconcilier cette partie du peuple qui
est en difficulté avec la démocratie qu
el fâcher avec la démocratie il faut que
ce soit un complément la démocratie
représentative et la dsi
vous donne la parole largement répondre
vous avez raison de vouloir étendre le
champ du référendum du référendum et
c'est quand même normal que quand il
s'agit de changer la constitution la
règle soit un petit peu plus compliqué
parce que si simplement le président
pouvait tout seul décidé de changer la
constitution en ayant 51% avec l'aspect
publicitaire qui est toujours derrière
eh bien on pourrait changer la
constitution la constitution la loi
fondamentale doit être plus compliqué a
changé un peu plus longue avec une
procédure un peu plus contraignantes
ayant des garde-fous que tout le show
yade dont vous nous avez parlé tout à
l'heure c'est que ce petit décalage
d'état constitutionnel ne pas dresser le
parlement contre le peuple
difficile à défendre parce qu'on a
toujours l'impression d'être
corporatisme les meilleurs commentaires
j'imaginais coco chose à défendre et
surtout il faut le faire de manière
raisonnée et de manière apaisée maryline
de manière légale évidemment marine le
pen défend l'état de droit marine le pen
a toujours défendu l'état de droit je
marche je remarque certains qui
s'offusquent de l'instauration de la
proportionnelle pas vous bien sûr que
certains qui s'offusquent que de faire
appel au peuple ne n'ont pas dit grand
chose quand on a tripatouillé l'état de
droit par la crise sanitaire et qu'on a
remis en cause un certain nombre de
berthet individuelles et collectives
attendez attendez attendez colle quand
même ça je veux dire on a eu un régime
d'exception là le dans le cadre d'une
large étendue ce qui est juste génial à
voir et j'ai violé je vais terminer à
l'article de loi et des violets ne parle
pas de loi qui serait violée si on parle
de droit maintenant là on parle très
clairement du choix du peuple souverain
c'est le peuple indépendant
attendez-vous gens là si en fait
j'ai pas besoin de votre aide je vous
remercie je suis majeur et vacciné pour
le mois de mai est vacciné nommé je vous
avais été trois à dire les arguments
écoutes dont certains des jeux que j'ai
trouvé très déplacé en faisant référence
au terrorisme voilà je trouve
extrêmement déplacé compte tenu de ce
que nous avons vécu comment faire
concrètement moi ce que je vois ce que
je veux dire pour ce milieu là parce que
c'est très important ce sera pas le
peuple contre le parlement marine le pen
considère que le parlement doit
redevenir la maison du peuple et qu'elle
doit redevenir la maison représentatif
du peuple c'est pour ça qu'elle souhaite
notamment la proportionnelle pour que ce
parlement retrouvent de la vigueur et
retrouve gérait un lien avec le peuple
souverain qui ne se sont pas comment
vous savez
cet état de droit la constitution telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui si vous voulez
faire cette priorité dans la
constitution comment vous faites tout
simplement quelle est la réponse
politique et juridique qu'est ce que
vous faites pour lever cet obstacle va
dans des
vagues et 89 à tient une route pour sa
part amassé par cette route là il va y
avoir un choix démocratique qui sera
celui du 24 avril c'est à dire que
marine le pen si elle est élue
présidente de la république et serait
lui sur des orientations sur un
programme dont l'instauration de la
priorité nationale dont le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne dont notamment
l'instauration de la proportionnelle à
l'assemblée nationale elle aura été non
pas plébiscité mais elle aura été élu
par là et je ne pense faire des lois non
bien sûr mais ce que je veux dire quand
on est élu toutes les lois qu'on apprend
que toutes les promesses qu'on ne sont
pas
les encres et facto devenue depuis
marqué depuis des années on a vu les
respecterais n'a voulu museler le peuple
voilà vu empêcher l'empêcher de tout
simplement de pouvoir décider et
d'ailleurs même quand ils votaient non
comme il a voté non en 2005 on a dit oui
après avec le travail est ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour que y est tout est ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour le feu pour
qu'il y ait deux façons une façon pour
faire des référendums pour des lois
simples pour légiférer selon le le
l'article 34 c'est à dire là la liste de
le domaine de la loi et une façon un peu
particulière quand il s'agit de de
changer la constitution est ce que pour
vous quand il s'agit de changer la
constitution vous comprenez où vous
accepter l'idée qu'il faut je les
revends dire que la constitution est une
loi comme les autres évidemment
évidemment et c'est pour se redresser
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que marine
le pen hir dans sa conférence de presse
a précisé sur le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne que tous les sujets devront
respecter intégralement le champ de la
constitution voilà vous passerez pas
vous attendre et d'avoir le parlement un
accord au parlement dans les deux
chambres vous attendrez le moment mais
les gosses irait avec le sénat mais au
gong et il n'y a pas de négociations si
vous êtes n'y a pas de négociations un
progrès quand elle sera une ration de la
loi quand elle l'est aussi dans des
ribéry mais évidemment mais on sera dans
le débat il y aura un débat au parlement
d'ailleurs elle l'a très bien dit sur le
concernant la proportionnelle oui contre
les modalités mais là on est sur un
sujet très précis mais c'est important
parce que c'est la priorité nationale vu
la même chose d'ailleurs avec la
question de la primauté du droit
français sur le droit européen là il
faudrait changer la conscience et le
même si je l'aimé bien entendu mutation
ce référendum parce que là vous me
parlez de le référendum pour lutter
contre l'immigration qui contient toutes
les mesures et dont l'instauration de la
priorité nationale la constitution il
faut changer la constitution pour ça
mais il serait bien évidemment mais donc
je veux dire donc le la fasse cause
commune complet mais est ce que vous
vous maintenez l'idée qu'il faille
passer par l'article 11 c'est ça que je
veux tu regardes accord on ne peut pas
changer la conseiller le conseil
national devrait dire non vous allez
faire quoi c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et qu'on va dire non le consoler
le québec
tu sionnel devra comment dirais-je voir
la décision du peuple souverain et non
qui aura fini non a priori mais si mais
si en fait ce n'est pas neuf sages qui
vont faire la loi à la paix
je voulais venir je sais que excusez moi
monsieur fabius ce n'est pas monsieur
fabre a empêché je vous explique le
souverain d'avoir la peau l'insee a
choisi visible en savait pas comment ça
allait déposer un décret le gouvernement
va déposer un décret un décret de
convocation je sais très bien comment ça
me ce décret de convocation va passer
devant le conseil que tu
vas là vous me parlez de viol la loire a
violé la décision démocratique du peuple
souverain il va pas violer il va il
valait sûr que d'essayer va dire ceux
des grèves alors mettez simplement ils
veulent à terme
le grand valley ces passionnés ont filé
vers l'asie le peuple sinon je suis
extrêmement attachée à la souveraineté
du peuple
l'article 3 de la constitution dit très
clairement la souveraineté nationale
appartient au peuple le peuple est le
titulaire du pouvoir souverain et le pen
l'a dit et sur ce point là je suis
d'accord avec elle le peuple souverain
va élire un ou une présidente 24 avril
supposons que ce soit marine le pen
conseil constitutionnel veille à la
régularité des élections de la plus
présente la république et c'est laurent
fabius qui proclamera marine le pen élue
dans un deuxième temps marine le pen
voudra faire un référendum le référendum
n'a pas lieu le 24 avril le référendum
aura lieu un autre instant cet autre
instant va être organisée par d'autres
règles dont le décret de convocation des
électeurs dont décret de convocation des
électeurs qui prend appui sur d'autres
normes constitutionnelles en l'espèce
l'article 11 or l'article 11 ne permet
pas de réviser la constitution un décret
de convocation des électeurs qui leur
demandent de se prononcer sur le
fondement de l'article 11 sur une
question constitutionnelle est un décret
contraire à la constitution vous dire le
conseil compte le conseil
constitutionnel le conseil
constitutionnel qui sera saisie de ne se
décrète pas de l'élection de madame le
pen de ce décret va dire
qu'effectivement par va
vraisemblablement dire je ne suis pas la
conséquence est chaîne que ce décret est
contraire free au fond le scénario que
vous dessinez je crois qu'on a bien
compris votre réponse pour vous redonner
parlement en tout cas le sujet est
important il ya une tribune dans le
monde plusieurs constitutionnalistes ont
mené par olivier beaud qui explique
marine le pen comme tous les leaders
autoritaire veut dynamiter la démocratie
libérale en faisant appel au peuple
regardez la une de l'humanité aussi
l'état de droit en péril attention aux
ravages de la démocratie il ya beaucoup
d'électeurs qui se disent comment notre
démocratie peut être préservé pour
excuser mari lorsqu'il fut une petite
nuance qui va être fait honte à emmanuel
macron je pense que mes collègues pour
lesquels j'ai beaucoup de respect ne
devrait pas ainsi opposé le peuple aux
institutions parce que le peuple et les
institutions vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure doit fonctionner de concert
c'est la logique de l'article de 89 de
faire fonctionner le peuple et les
institutions de concerts dans la logique
de montesquieu qui était que le pouvoir
arrête le pouvoir et ainsi ils vont de
concert et pour réviser la constitution
il y a des contre-pouvoirs il faut qu'il
y ait d'abord le parlement qui se
prononce et ensuite pleinement quand
vous avez dit c'est pas à laurent fabius
qui va décider au fond de ce que veut le
peuple qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
est ce que vous imaginez qu'on puisse
dissoudre le conseil constitutionnel
renommée des sages est ce que vous
imaginez qu'on puisse aller jusqu'à
remettre à plat la constitution
elle-même pour lever ces obstacles
mais déjà je pense qu'il faut pas verser
dans les caricatures les accusations
d'autoritarisme notamment du journal
l'humanité qui a il ya quelques années
et des décennies titre et staline
l'homme que nous aimons le plus bon je
pense qu'il faut raison garder il faut
remettre un petit peu les choses en
perspective marine le pen je leur dis
est une démocrate alors je sais que ça
peut choquer certains je sais que
certains aient serré d'en faire un
épouvantail ou comment dirais-je faire
des allusions à viktor orban je rappelle
que viktor orban d'ailleurs et premier
ministre d'un pays qui membres de
l'union européenne ont marre il est par
définition une démocratie on prend
l'exemple de la pologne l'europe a
sanctionné un la pologne après la fusion
constitue
maintenant la page est heureusement de
la semaine
de l'europe pour violation du craignent
enfin hongrie et la pologne sont
précisément poursuivi par la commission
européenne pour violation de l'état de
droit donc oui ce sont des états de
droit il remet en cause quelques règles
c'était important ici à la chaîne
parlementaire d'avoir ce d'avoir ce
débat chacun se fera son opinion en tout
cas l'exposé des articles fondamentaux
de notre constitution sont pour le moins
très clair on va regarder maintenant
patrick million' à ce que propose
emmanuel macron alors c'est un peu un
work in progress comme on dit en bon
français puisque on découvre de
nouvelles propositions sur le septennat
renouvelables par exemple à la faveur de
cet entre deux tours on a essayé de
regarder à la fois des programmes et
puis les propos du président candidat
avec hadouk trio
stratégie électorale en vue du second
tour ou changement de cap emmanuel
macron est en train d'évoluer sur le
scrutin proportionnelle pour les
législatives
lui qui souhaitait l'instaurer de façon
partielle pour au moins 15 % des députés
dans sa réforme constitutionnelle de
2018 seraient désormais prêts à aller
encore plus loin je les dis c'est dans
mon projet si les institutions doivent
être rénovées il me semble qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut améliorer
avoir par exemple plus de
proportionnelle pour mieux représenter
l'ensemble des forces politiques à
l'assemblée nationale intégral pense
qu'on peut aller jusque là je n'y suis
pas opposé en ce qui me concerne par
ailleurs emmanuel macron à dégainer
l'idée d'un retour au septennat
présidentiel renouvelable deux fois sept
ans donc et pour réformer la
constitution il préconise une nouvelle
réflexion c'est de pouvoir mettre en
place une commission transpartisane avec
toutes les sensibilités politiques
qu'ils puissent ensuite soumettre aux
deux assemblées une proposition de
réforme de notre constitution pour
précisément la rénover l'améliorer
marquée par la crise des gilets jaunes
qui avaient réclamé davantage de
représentation du peuple via les riques
des référendums d'initiative citoyenne
mais aussi par un chiffre alarmant en
décembre dernier selon l'ifop
48% des français estimaient que l'état
de la démocratie s'était détérioré au
cours du montage emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui le président candidat a pour
ambition dans son second mandat de mieux
intégrer les citoyens aux jeux
politiques de les consulter davantage en
lançant ce qu'il nomme un grand débat
permanent projet esquissé dans une vidéo
de campagne dès mars dernier et cette
nouvelle méthode
nous la lancerons à travers quelques
grands chantiers un grand chanter sur
l'école d'un grand chantier sur la santé
un grand chantier sur la réforme
institutionnelle et il faudra en
imaginer d'autres mais ça veut dire quoi
au juste un grand débat permanent
va-t-il céder à la tentation
référendaire à la sauce macron où cela
pourrait-il plus de ressembler à une
convention citoyenne comme celle qu'il
avait lancée sur le climat pendant son
premier mandat emmanuel macron a encore
neuf jours pour préciser ses intentions
patrick mignola c'est vrai que c'est
assez flou en fait pendant ce sont des
questions fondamentales vous avez
compris quoi consultation citoyenne peut
être un référendum à l'issue de cette
consultation sur des questions
fondamentales il a évoqué les retraites
la fin de vie grande commission un peu
comme une commission balladur avec tous
les partis grand débat faire maintenant
qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui va faire
qu'est ce qu'il veut faire tirer les
conséquences de 5 années d'expérience et
parmi les choses qu'on n'a pas bien fait
c'est effectivement on n'est pas arrivé
à faire évoluer les institutions et au
demeurant qui est de l'abstention et du
vote extrême au premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle a montré qu' on
avait échoué en la matière et pourquoi
on a échoué parce que très rapidement au
bout d'une année une année et demie vous
n'avez plus ou très difficilement dans
l'opinion publique dans la population et
au parlement les majorités suffisamment
apaisé qui peuvent se dégager pour aller
vers une révision constitutionnelle est
donc sur le modèle de ce qui est manuel
macron propose pour la santé et pour
l'école qui sont deux grands piliers
importants on voit que on met beaucoup
d'argent mais pour autant on parvient
pas à améliorer à rendre le système plus
efficient plus satisfaisant pour la
population et on propose de mettre tout
le monde autour de la table pour que sur
le terrain et ça c'est très concret dans
n'importe quelle mairie on sait comment
on organise de la concertation le dieu
on sait comment on organise le débat
les instituts en clair au moins il y
avait alors on va voir si c'est faisable
ou pas mais il ya un référendum sur
plusieurs sujets chez marine le pen
le référendum on sait pas si
ça doit arriver à la fin c'est pas une
baguette magique ce en quoi je diffère
avec cette idée ou quand on arrive tout
d'un coup boom à leon lance trois ou
quatre référendum on casse la
constitution on casse la loi et vous
verrez tous les problèmes seront réglés
pas du tout on attend
et à mettre tout le monde d'accord
consensus citoyen c'est quand vous
parlez du nombre d'années du mandat
présidentiel quand vous parlez du
scrutin quand vous parlez de
l'organisation territoriale à laquelle
plus personne comprend et aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avec un tiers des français
qui étaient allés voter les dernières
aux élections locales si vous mettez pas
tout le monde autour de la table c'est
impossible d'avancer vous avez vu
nicolas sarkozy effet le conseiller
territorial pour qu'on comprenne mieux
comment fonctionnaient les régions et
les départements françois hollande deux
ans après a décidé de ne pas la peine
non
proportionnelle mais on s'est rendu
compte parce que c'est cracher dans
l'été 2010 8 sur cette révision
constitutionnelle mais on n'a pas pu
aller au bout les oppositions étaient
contre nous et d'ailleurs ben alors
assemblée nationale on faisait partie à
l'époque il était contre avec moi qui
vous ai un peu terne a bien compris que
vous aviez utilisé qui avait rien à voir
avec la constitution française pour nous
éviter de faire la révision conçu pour
ce débat sur la proportionnelle
intégrale de la dir intégral et vous et
moi on y voit clair vous évidemment au
modem vous voulez défendent et des biens
sur des décennies
ce que je soutiens mais la
proportionnelle avec prime majoritaire
nationale comme dans les conseils
régionaux
dans les conseillerez
prime majoritaire c'est la liste arrivée
en tête qui arrive en tête en fait tu
prends une prime de 25% comme dans les
régions où de 50% comme dans les
méridiens c'est un mais c'est pas la
presse conventionnelle moi si je regarde
toutes les personnes qui étaient
frustrés de ne pas pouvoir s'exprimer au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et qui vont être frustrés
au deuxième tour parce qu'ils peuvent
pas exprimer s'exprimer selon leur
sensibilité
on va avoir la même difficulté la seule
proportionnelle qui vaille c'est la
proportionnelle intégrale au sens de
celle de 1986 celle de françois
mitterrand qui avait dégagé d'ailleurs
une majorité contrairement à ce qui se
dit ici ou là la proportionnelle de
dégager de majorité c'est pas vrai il y
avait à l'époque pour le rpr et l'udf et
une majorité qui s'était dégagée avec
alors là vous êtes d'accord j'imagine
sur la proportion avec le modem c'est un
combat avec rajon et pas que sur la
proportionnelle parce que toutes les
promesses démocratiques damon macron été
trahi la banque de la démocratie est une
belle idée de françois bayrou et
d'ailleurs on comptait sur lui au début
du mandat qu'elle aurait permis
notamment à que tous les candidats tous
les partis puissent être soutenus
financièrement et campagne électorale
exactement voilà tout à fait donc ses
promesses ont été trahis la
proportionnelle évidemment été trahi le
référendum jamais monsieur macron à
consulter les français par la voie du
référendum est pire que ça il n'a jamais
écouté les français quand il eu des
messages forts et gilet jaune c'était
quoi c'était sentiments ne pas être
écoutés ne pas être entendu d'être
méprisés là je pense qu'il aurait fallu
redonner la parole au peuple souverain
on a eu quoi on a eu une arnaque
démocratique qui était un faux débat un
débat au finalement qui s'est évanoui
dans la nature avec des musiciens où il
met même en retrait du mois le résultat
c'est quoi le résultat le résultat c'est
l'abstention qui s'est sentie series
avec les milliards des
millions de gens qu'on travaillait le
pouvoir d'achat s'était rendu au
mais pourquoi monsieur mac restons sur
les institutions et d'apprendre comme le
schéma qu'on ferait ce qui n'a pas su
faire pendant cinq ans thomas legrand
c'est intéressant parce que de toute
façon quel que soit le vainqueur de
l'élection marine le pen ou emmanuel
macron sept prochaines législatives y
aura pas de proportionnelle faut bien
que les gens qui nous regardent le
comprennent c'est à dire que de toute
façon on repartira avec quand même une
vraie question démocratique au regard
des résultats on pourrait imaginer
puisque je rappelle que pour instaurer
la proportionnelle là il ne faut pas
changer la constitution donc on peut
passer par l'article 11 si on veut le
faire par un référendum ce combat une
loi simple suffirait mais si on veut le
faire par référendum on peut passer par
article un référendum avant non pas pour
réinstaurer la professional est en cours
de héros t en principe dire qu'on
dissout pour pouvoir 40 jours après
refaire une élection
non j'y crois pas ça pourrait être le
prince de hombourg et réclamé sa fille
je crois que ce serait pas souhaité
qu'elle soit l'issue de la présidence
et qui a un petit peu problématique
s'est résumée par la façon dont vous
avez posé la question à un soutient
emmanuel macron au lieu de lui demander
et c'est normal on fait ça pour lui
demander qu'est ce que vous allez faire
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'est ce
qu'ils devraient faire vous lui avez
demandé qu'est-ce que vous avez compris
qu'il va faire c'est à dire que la
décision la question qu emmanuel macron
doit poser elle est peut-être
institutionnel mais elle est d'abord
surtout sa façon de gouverner et ils
gouvernent il ya quatre de deux
personnes qui gouvernent il n'y a même
pas la république en marche lui en tant
que journal a tort moi je téléphone pas
à défendre la république en marche pour
savoir ce qui va se faire parce que ils
me posent la question quasiment toi qu'a
eue l'elysée qu'elle se lançait ouais
donc là ça pose un problème moi j'ai
passé cinq ans
j'ai passé ça je préfère les 80
demandant ce qu'était le maquereau
nispel vous pouvez aussi qualité du
pouvoir ça vous dit qu'on va faire une
consolidation pour précisément le monde
auto bleue
jeudi c'est super et que vous ayez que
vous avez tout à fait raison je suis
juste un peu étonné et plutôt je suis
plutôt votre avis parce que je pense
qu'il fallait la proportionnelle
intégrale pour les prochaines
initiatives donc il fallait la faire
avant et on aurait très bien pu la faire
par la loi donc mais bon j'espère pour
que je puisse croire à ce que vous dites
sur la réforme des institutions
est plus écoutée il faudrait aussi qu
emmanuel macron 17 changent de mentalité
de gouverner et je vais écouter alain
juppé rien peut-être je voudrais qu'il
ya un parti politique
la majorité comment va s'organiser la
majorité qui va et qu'on puisse savoir
jean philippe desrosiers on se rend
compte par exemple sur sur les retraites
le bouger sur les retraites 64 oui il a
été libéré en se bouger là
dans la majorité vous vous croyez ça
fait très très longtemps qu'on parle de
la proportionnelle d'associer les
citoyens à la décision de faire en sorte
que on sort de cette crise de la
représentation je pensais que ça y est
on est au moment de l'action là ou pas
alors je n'en sais rien premièrement je
ne participe pas au programme ni à la
majorité des manuels macron je pense
qu'en en effet il faut cesser de prendre
les électeurs pour des imbéciles ce qui
commence par effectivement tenir les
promesses qu'elle on s'engage à
respecter le droit est allé jusqu'au
bout de la démarche engagée un débat
c'est très sain sur la proportionnelle
sur les questions démocratiques je crois
qu'il faut engager un débat il sera
nécessaire que ce débat
ne soit pas comme par exemple la
convention citoyenne sur le climat où il
ya eu un débat il ya eu beaucoup de
discussions il n'en n'est pas une en est
ressorti quelques chose mais en tout cas
dans le droit il n'en est pas ressorti
grand chose que les massifs
oui mais qui n'a pas beaucoup repris les
conclusions de la deûle à croire les ans
et tous les jours qui aujourd'hui
doivent changer leur chaudière changer
leur voiture et tous les maires qui
doivent construire plus dense venu je
peux vous dire qu'il ya des choses dans
la loi
dit simplement que la convention
citoyenne elle même les conclusions et
des propositions qu'elle avait faites
n'ont pas été très clair mais pour
conclure sur sur ce sujet
faire refaire adhérer le peuple la
démocratie c'est un travail au long
cours il ya pas un coup de baguette
magique qui va tous transformés est-ce
que la proportionnelle va le permettre
personnellement j'ai toujours été très
réservée sur la proportionnelle mais
peut-être et engageant un débat sur le
sujet mais il ne faut pas croire en
revanche que la proportionnelle va faire
que automatiquement le peuple va revenir
aux urnes avec plus de 80 je pense que
c'est un ensemble de mesures et un
travail au long cours qui doit commencer
aujourd'hui tout le monde ou presque
sait compter aujourd'hui tout le monde
ou presque sait lire aujourd'hui pas
tout le monde est loin s'en faut c'est
ce qu'est un parlement ce qu'est un
conseil à un conseil municipal altéra et
je crois que pézenas
et la démocratie pour faire éduquer et
créer de véritables citoyens qui iront
effectivement voter eh bien on va
s'arrêter là merci merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat patrick mignola
thomas legrand jean philippe desrosiers
julien au doute merci à vous on va
cueillir à présent notre grand témoin il
est philosophe il enseigne à l'école
normale supérieure et vient de faire
paraître un essai le désir de résister
chez odile jacob c'est un appel à ne pas
céder à la mélancolie ambiante en
cultivant l'esprit critique et va nous
dire exactement ce qu'il met derrière
cette expression il vient de signer
aussi dans libération une lettre ouverte
à la genette ce tentés par l'abstention
on a plein de questions à poser à marc
crépon comme les skis ce sujet de
thibaut enac
si on vous invite marc crépon c'est que
le philosophe que vous êtes a pris le
parti de lancer un cri d'alarmé au
lendemain du premier tour de la
présidentielle dans une lettre ouverte
adressée à la jeunesse tentés par
l'abstention
vous écrivez choisir entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen n'est pas
choisir entre charybde et scylla ainsi
la déception ressentie par certains dont
vous envers emmanuel macron ne doit pas
faire oublier qu un risque plus
important est en jeu didou la démocratie
ne consiste pas toujours malheureusement
à choisir le meilleur elle est aussi
parfois et il serait redoutable de
l'oublier d'éviter le pire marc crépon
vous êtes philosophe directeur de
recherche au cnrs parmi vos thèmes de
recherche la question de la violence du
langage et la politique
trois questions qui se recoupent dans
les pièges du populisme que vous
analysez et dénoncer sa recette est
toujours la même il commence par
désigner ceux et celles qui l'estiment
constituer un danger pour tous les
autres ça peut être les étrangers les
sans papiers les émigrés les homosexuels
au brésil il divise donc il prétend
parler au peuple de ne pas mais il
commence par le diviser ainsi le
populisme est il selon vous inséparable
de la violence à vos yeux le discours de
marine le pen fut-il police et en
contient les germes la politique
identitaire que projette la présidente
du rassemblement national est animé d'un
esprit de vengeance elle se nourrit du
fantasme d'une identité nationale
restaurée qui parce qu'elle ne
correspond à aucune réalité ne pourra
s'imposer autrement que par la violence
vous dites ainsi craindre une remise en
cause des droits des libertés et des
politiques discriminatoires danger
d'autant plus important dites-vous qu'il
semble déjà en partie accepté dès lors
marc crépon vous appelez à résister face
à l'apathie qui menace de nous gagner ce
que vous appelez la sédimentation de
l'inacceptable de quoi s'agit-il
de l'extraordinaire qui finit par
devenir ordinaire
au point qu'on ne s'étonne pas qu on ne
s'indigne plus de rien un peu comme dans
les récits de kafka c'est pour ça que le
populisme nous fait si peur alors marc
crépon si votre message est clair sur ce
qu'il convient de faire selon vous le 24
avril prochain
au delà nous voilà quelque peu démunis
comment résister aujourd'hui comment
faire reculer le populisme et quelle
forme devrait prendre alors la colère
citoyenne
bonsoir marc crépon bonsoir et merci
d'être là ce soir beaucoup de questions
envoyées à vous poser derrière ce titre
aussi le désir de résister lors et ont
perdu chez odile jacob mais on commence
avec cette tribune publiée aujourd'hui
dans libération à l'adresse de la
jeunesse résigné d'ailleurs est ce que
c'est un homme de gauche qui s'adresse à
cette jeunesse aujourd'hui tentés par
l'abstention où il faut bien que je
sorte du bois oui c'est plutôt un homme
de gauche on va dire à l'autonome de
gauche vous l'assumer pleinement vous
vous expliquer à cette genèse tentés par
l'abstention que renvoyait dos à dos
emmanuel macron et marine le pen serait
une erreur pour ne pas dire une faute
expliquez nous en quoi refusé de choisir
ce serait la pire des solutions et bien
parce que d'abord je pense qu'une grande
partie de la jeunesse de gauche qui a
massivement voté pour jean luc mélenchon
c'est pour ça qu'il est à 22%
cette jeunesse là et
désabusé désabusé d'être une fois de
plus privés du second tour dont elle a
rêvé parce que dans le fond
la démocratie notre idéalisation de la
démocratie voudrait que lorsque nous
votons par un candidat dans cette phase
finale
de l'élection présidentielle eh bien
nous soyons portée par l'espoir qu'il va
réellement apporté dans la société dans
la vie publique les changements qu'on
attend et qu'on espère
c'est passé faire la leçon
je veux parler je veux surtout pas ils
n'ont pas besoin qu'on leur fasse la
leçon je veux les avertir d'une ou deux
choses elle est donc cette jeunesse là
est à l'impression qu'elle est une fois
de plus privé de son second tour de
l'élection de la fois de plus privé de
ses rêves
et et pourquoi elle est privée de ses
rêves d'or parce qu'elle ne se reconnaît
pas dans le front national c'est une
jeunesse qui n'a jamais été attiré par
la politique identitaire que demande que
préconise fin que promet marine le pen
c'est une jeunesse qui est tout à fait
soucieuse aussi de l'état de droit du
respect des droits et des libertés
fondamentales et qui sait en un certain
sens quand même ce qui risque d'être
perdu mais en même temps c'est une
jeunesse qui en veut énormément aimé le
masque elle vous dit pas ce que vous
enseignez à l'aura de brillant normalien
seulement j'aurais pas seulement monde
et puis j'ai beaucoup de jeunes dont on
serait que à la sorbonne par exemple il
ya déjà des des manifestations des
blocages a pris wifi qu'est ce qu'elle
vous dit qu'elle mobilise cette jeunesse
écouter ce qu'elle me dit si vous n'êtes
pas seulement à moi non je n'ai pas
vocation à faire parler la vocation être
sa place mais ce que j'entends beaucoup
voilà c'est que
le principal reproche ils adressent à
emmanuel macron cdh à boire à multiples
reprises pendant son quinquennat
brouiller les frontières qui dans le
fond c'est par
la démocratie à laquelle ils sont
attachés et ce qu'il redoute avec marine
le pen donc ce qui revient tout le temps
c'est le démantèlement brutal des camps
de migrants
au début du quinquennat
c'est les violences policières pour
réprimer le mouvement des filets jaunes
c'est l'arrogance la suffisance et le
sentiment que dans le fond
l'attention accordée aux plus démunis
l'attention accordée aux plus
défavorisés aux oubliés de l'histoire et
du progrès
qu'il n'y a plus de choix au fond que
que choisir par défaut est une
contrainte insupportable c'est ça vous
les sentez tentés par l'abstention oui
ils ont l'impression et louis sont
tentés par l'abstention oui j'ai écrit
cette tribune parce que j'en ai entendu
beaucoup qui sont tentés par la pression
j'ai peur du résultat du 24 avril et
parce que je me suis dit qu'il était de
ma responsabilité
voilà de dire deux ou trois choses et
les choses que je tenais à dire
essentiellement c'est que ça n'est pas
la même chose ça n'est pas la même chose
et que
le gie dans laquelle
était inscrit le programme d' emmanuel
macron et celle dans laquelle s'inscrit
le programme de marine le pen tout les
sépare ils ne sont pas inscrits dans la
même histoire ils n'ont pas les mêmes
héritage et la france qu'ils promettent
ne sera pas la même bien sûr mais quand
vous écrivez quel que soit le nom qui
sortira des urnes
au fond il ya quand même une différence
majeure de la résistance selon que sa
marine le pen ou emmanuel macron vous
dites la résistance ne sera pas la même
oui parce que je ne lui veux dire quoi
ça oui puisque je ne pense pas je t'aime
prévu que
emmanuel macron porte atteinte à l'état
de droit
vous venez apparaîtrait mouvement
je ne pense pas qu'ils portent atteinte
à la constitution je ne pense pas une
seule seconde qu'ils fassent preuve
d'amateurisme juridique
par rapport à la violence et à faire
l'état de droit
l'extrême droite quand elle arrive au
pouvoir c'est un verbe ou quelqu'un elle
le grignote elle le grignote petit à
petit c'est ce qui s'est passé
dans la hongrie de viktor orban c'est ce
qui s'est passé en pologne c'est
insidieux c'est long mais c'est
implacable et ça se fait alors justement
à l'heure où résiste au premier sens du
terme en ukraine où les hommes les
jeunes aussi prennent les armes et ce
mot de résistance n'a jamais été aussi
puissant et fort au coeur de l'europe
qu'est ce que ça veut dire résister
aujourd'hui dans une démocratie
apathique fatigué qui cherchent avant
tout son confort on le on le sent
bientôt alors d'abord je voudrais dire
une chose c'est que j'ai beaucoup parler
déjà de la résistance en ukraine et la
résistance en ukraine elle est motivée
essentiellement parce que les ukrainiens
à traves savent très bien ils n'ont pas
la mémoire courte ils savent très bien
ce qu'ils perdront si effectivement il
retourne sous la coupe de la russie ils
perdront justement le processus
démocratique qui tant bien que mal en
ukraine comme en moldavie comme un jour
j -c mis en place et qui a permis des
institutions culturelles libre une
presse diversifiée
pluriel la liberté d'opinion tout ce
dont il faut bien le reconnaître le
peuple russe et privés depuis une
trentaine d'années ce sont des peuples
qui ont suivi des trajectoires
différentes
après l'effondrement alors évidemment
cette résistance à l part de la jeunesse
elle peut faire écho à nos sociétés la
menace n'est quand même pas la même mais
n'en sont pas naître la menace du quand
même pas la même on est bien qu'est ce
que ça veut dire cette résistance dont
vous parlez le désir de résister qu est
ce que vous mettez dans ce mot est ce
que c'est de la colère est ce que c'est
de l'indignation qu'il faut retrouver
est ce que c'est de la révolte ou un
esprit critique encore bien différent
alors le désir de résister en fait il
faut l'entendre en un double sens à
partir de l'objet de la résistance la
première chose à laquelle il importe de
résister c'est ce que j'appelle dans le
livre la mélancolie de l'histoire et
cette mélancolie d'histoire nous avons
bien des raisons d'être rattrapé par
elle et je me pense beaucoup à cette
génération l'un en me projetant dans la
mienne ya 30 ans et quand même les
perspectives étaient plus cette
génération là elle a affronté la
pandémie et le risque de leurs
répétitions elle affronte la question du
réchauffement climatique voilà que
maintenant la menace nucléaire menton
qui a toujours été là mais est beaucoup
plus présente beaucoup plus proche donc
elle elle
procure elles provoquent le sentiment
dans le faucon est dépossédé de sa
propre vie qu'on a dépossédé de sa
propre vie qu'on n'a pas d'avenir
et que dans le fond notre vie
ne nous appartient pas parce qu'on ne
peut plus être les sujets de notre
propre histoire donc résister à la
meinau connu de l'histoire sert devenir
le sujet de sa propre histoire ce qui
suppose comment on y parvient à
retrouver ce désir là alors comment on y
parvient à retrouver se destine d'abord
en ayant
conscience du type de piège dans
laquelle cette belle inconnue de
l'histoire peut nous embarquer et le
premier des pièges je crois c'est
de céder à la tentation de la violence
de se précipiter dans les bras de régime
ou de partis
politiques qui effectivement promet des
solutions radicales promettent
la violence donc le c'est pour ça que je
disais à l'instant qu'il y avait deux
sens il fallait entendre la résistance
en deux sens le premier seul à résister
à la mélancolie de l'histoire et
le deuxième sens c'est de résister à ce
que moi j'ai identifié au populisme
c'est à dire al'inverse les
simplifications de l'histoire les
simplifications de la politique
les jugements à l'emporte-pièce et c'est
à cet esprit critique alors et voilà et
vous permettez juste en de répondre à
l'une des questions qui m'est posée
pourquoi l'esprit critique il faut pas
entendre l'esprit critique comme le
mauvais esprit ou comme les esprits
grincheux qui critique tout l'esprit
critique c'est l'esprit qui fait preuve
de discernement qui prend du recul qui
prend de la distance qui est capable de
séparer le vraisemblable du vrai le faux
du vrai lait et ça je crois que c'est ce
dont nous avons absolument pas besoin de
ça nous avons absolument besoin pas le
mois prochain pas dans six mois mam est
là maintenant entre les deux tours des
élections le désir de résister un esprit
critique pour notre temps c'est chez
odile jacob pour rester avec moi marc
crépon d'accueillir nos chroniqueurs
vous allez le voir c'est l'heure du scan
passé au crible cet entre deux tours
avec les fines lames que je vous
présente tout de suite
mais revenez donc il ya les deux pas de
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
molle vous propose le rose dalmore
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la france orange
ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
bose exclu il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur caritas a pas de mystère c'est
le vol
enoh scanner ce soir mariette darrigrand
bonsoir vous allez nous parler vous êtes
sémiologue je le rappelle fondatrice de
la fondation des mots comme on
s'aimerait de l'observatoire des me
pardonnez moi vous allez vous parler du
vote des femmes du vote féminin les
françaises dans ce premier tour mais on
commence avec vous ce soir comme chaque
fois l'oeil de blacko attiré par qui et
pourquoi aujourd'hui auto yeux c'est que
voilà ça y est macron étant entré en
campagne ça ne fait plus de doute il a
attendu le second tour mais là il y est
jupiter et donc redescendu de son olympe
et dont il s'est mis à portée de base
des français vous avez cette expression
qu'emploient les élus locaux quand ils
veulent parler leur la particularité de
l'an murray pour montrer que c'est pas
son genre de se dégonfler qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il a été donc à carvin une
commune du pas-de-calais où marine le
pen avait fait 40 % au 1er de la
présidentielle donc là il est en terrain
hostile et son équipe de campagne a
tourné un joli petit film vous allez
voir qu'il raconte sa visite
[Musique]
je suis très content qu'il vienne dans
des
dans des villes où
feng est plutôt hausse à ce qu'il faut
je suis très content qu'il ait ni si
j'adore j'adore ma région j'adore mon
département
quand il en a j'en suis très content
tout à fait passé comme ça évidemment
évidemment ça n'est pas passé comme ça
mais en même temps caen mâcon va se
balader sur les terres du fn ils doutent
bien qui va se faire engueuler pensais
bien que c'était prévu ce qui lui est
arrivé donc au premier tour il est
proposé donc la retraite à 65 ans pour
rassembler pour piquer les électeurs de
pécresse donc ça c'est fait les
électeurs de pain cresson en sa poche
donc maintenant il faut s'adresser aux
classes populaires ou plutôt c'était
l'occasion pour les classes populaires
de s'adresser aux candidats à voter non
alors que non ceux qui sont dans les
bureaux où oui mes potes qui travaillait
mme ashton la preuve on y travaille dur
non d'accord eh ben on est on est déjà
on n'est pas si loin
non est-ce qu'il faut baisser les
retenir vouloir monter pour la montée
oui on est d'accord oui pour le mettre
en oeuvre le rsa ceux qui travaillent ce
pas alors aller travailler
et ça c'est encore mieux que le clip
officiel parce que bon sens le coût de
65 ans ça permet à macron d'expliquer en
fait c'est progressif de 65 ans c'est en
2030 nepad et qui va être élu donc déjà
ça calme un petit peu ce qui inquiète et
puis surtout on se rend compte que les
classes populaires par exemple l'idée
que ont ils failli bosser pour avoir le
rsa ça les choque pas au contraire très
bien après à priver les gens de rs 1 oui
ces prix aussi quelques baffes il s'est
même fait insulter le président mais là
aussi c'était prévu franchement c'était
prévu donc non il ya eu le gars qu'il
s'est adressé à lui en lui disant qu'il
était arrogant méprisant machiavélique
ce qui n'est pas faux d'ailleurs mais
bon même temps manquerait un peu
impavide il a pris çà sans s'énerver
sans reculer non plus mais j'ai montré
un extrait il était finalement plus mal
à l'aise que face à une charge brutale
c'est quand il a dû s'expliquer sur le
fait qu'il avait envie des marques d'en
garder les français là il n'a pas été
très bons on regarde on
mérite ou non j'ai fait ce que
d'emmerder les genres d'accord doit
quand même fallu comme une insulte oui
non mais quand vous dites à quelqu'un me
dit je t'emmerde
implacable c'est l'oxymore de trop comme
andy emmerder affectueusement ses
cellules en même temps qui ne passe plus
à l'est en même temps de trop hier
strasbourg aussi là il a été chahuté
non mais là c'est l'histoire là il se
régale macron l'avion bah oui il en
avait marre passer son temps au
téléphone avec poutine puis le conseil
des ministres imaginez comment ces
chiens entre bruno le maire le fayot
darmanin qui de piquer sa place la up il
était sur les sur l'estrade et puis qui
sait que sa principale qualité les prix
les français disent oui il al'étoffe
d'un président auquel right stuff en
même temps leurs proches et qui arrogant
l'a dit il est hautain y regarde les
gens de haut donc là de redescendre au
milieu des français ben forcément ça
corrige un peu le défaut de son image
donc il s'est fait un plaisir de se
faire apostropher et de répondre avec
les insoumis qui était venu à un meeting
de strasbourg
[Applaudissements]
je suis je suis interpellé par des
militants d'extrême gauche qui si ils
veulent bien l'écouter je vais leur
répondre parce que d'abord lisf n'est
pas dans ma poche et mais la réforme
fiscale qu'on a fait en début de
quinquennat a permis de faire revenir de
l'investissement de re créer de la
richesse
oui mais on choisit sf on s'en fout
c'est pas du tout le problème chacun son
avis sur l' isf là ce qu'on voit c'est
que macron il est à l'aise au milieu de
français on l'a pris sur les 65 ans ont
l'anglais comme quoi il était arrogant
on l'abat bras il est au milieu des gens
à s aider principal défaut qu'il est en
train de corriger surprise qui perd pas
le nord va bien compris que ce qui doit
faire maintenant c'est gagner des voix à
gauche on a compris que les gens qui
avaient ce que tu es nouveau en 2001 de
voter à gauche et lé quartier ce qu'on
appelait les banlieues dans le temps
donc l'occasion faisant le larron quand
l'occasion se présente le larron la
saisie donc si comment faire pour
inciter les jeunes à voter macron
regarder
à huy
ce
qui est beau raid féministe oui moi j
féministes pour l'égalité femmes hommes
je peux me permettre d'être indiscret
oui vous porter un voile par choix s'est
imposé devant les caméras non je vous le
dit
avoir une jeune fille qui porte le voile
à strasbourg qui dit est ce que vous
êtes féministe c'est la meilleure des
réponses à toutes les bêtises que
j'entends parce que doute côté madame le
pen qui dirait veulent sera interdit sur
la place publique avec moi bayer
mélenchon n'a pas besoin de donner de
consignes il se débrouille très bien
tout seuls manqueront donc pour ceux qui
s'inquiétaient du fait qu'il s'implique
parce que la campagne les voilà rassurés
le gars est bien décidé à faire 50 plus
ça va pas être facile de déloger pour
marine le pen un certain talent vous
diriez oui talent
je pense que quand même convaincre même
ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec vous
même ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec qui
je suis pas sûr que ce soit de nature
suffisante à convaincre la jeunesse
mélenchonistes de voter pour lui
24 alors mariette vous nous parler des
votes des femmes dans cette
présidentielle oui parce qu'il ya quand
même un effet du vote féminin les deux
finalistes ont été ont cartonné plus
près des femmes que des hommes et puis
par exemple eric zemmour au contraire il
a fait un très très très mauvais score
c'est du simple au double entre les
femmes et les hommes est ce assez c'est
nouveau par rapport à 2010 est il ya
quelque chose qui est un peu genre et
dense est dans cette élection alors
pourquoi pourquoi les femmes candidates
n'ont elles pas car c'est une vraie
question parce qu'on n'avait jamais eu
autant de femmes et l on a par marine le
pen fait des très mauvais score alors
pourquoi c'est curieux parce qu'elle
avait quand même des mesures
intéressantes anne hidalgo par exemple
avait une mesure phare pour les
féministes qui est le le budget de
l'état consacré à la lutte contre la
violence sexiste cl les associations
demandent un milliard d'euros ce qui est
énorme ce qui n'est pas fait aujourd'hui
elle avait ça dans son panier ça n'a pas
été vu et quant à quant à valérie
pécresse vont laver un truc un peu
démagogique qui était lutter contre la
précarité menstruel comme on dit parra
baisse des taux de la tva sur certaines
produits d'hygiène féminine mais surtout
elle avait une mesure intéressante aussi
qui est laide la location pour les
aidants et vous savez que les aidants
quand on dit les aidant les gens qui est
de leurs parents âgés par exemple etc
abbas et des femmes en fête est alors
donc des mesures concrètes mais qui on
peut rapporter si on peut dire aux
candidates voilà c'est là où ça
m'intéresse comme ses 1001 pas ce qu'est
ce que ce qu'elle est le signe que ça
nous donne ça nous donne le signe que
c'est moins une question de réalité que
de symbolique en fait ce qui n'a pas été
assez apparences et des figures de
femmes peu archétypale des vraiment des
rôles
si on prend un hidalgo nathalie arthaud
si vous voulez c'est la candidate comme
un candidat à l'appel on sait l'individu
c'est pas une femme
et puis si on prend valérie pécresse bah
elle était un peu la petite fille en
fait pas la vraie femme elle avait
toujours son papa jacques chirac aux
biens sont par un nicolas sarkozy
marine le pen alors elle est comprise à
la marine le pen allant dans l'image de
femme qu'alain car oui parce qu'elle a
fait monter un archétype c'est ça ça
dédiabolisation c'est qu'elle est
devenue une maman donne une mère gentil
avec ses petits chats et puis une maman
protectrice pour le corps social une
femme célibataire aussi que la gare
exactement non parental il a dit aux
électeurs de mélenchon mais oui on nous
a trahis par qu'il ne vous protège plus
est iad maman marine se propose il ya
deux millions de femmes
familles monoparentales ça veut dire des
femmes et l a bien compris cet électorat
simplement quand on passe de filles
parce qu'elle était la fille de son père
marcial un maire ont loupé une case qui
est la femme pas pareil quand même tout
à fait un et donc c'est là où je pense
elle commet une erreur elle n'est pas
assez féministe au sens du néo féminisme
actuelle qui a monté cette notion-là est
quelque chose de très important qui est
ce quiz qui a été appelé la sororité
c'est à dire une solidarité entre femmes
et le fait qu'il peut y avoir ça ce
serait nouveau des femmes qui
travaillent ensemble autour de marine le
pen on peut pas dire qu'il y en ait
beaucoup et que dire pour terminer
rapidement de la place de la femme chez
emmanuel macron alors emmanuel ackroyd
du point de vue des soeurs il n'est pas
dans la sororité classique des
féminicides un homme mais il a des
petites soeurs et en particulier marlène
schiappa qui a quand même beaucoup
compté dans la preuve enfin dans son
premier quinquennat non la question que
je me mets dans le sèche-linge ne
manqueront pas non non non vrai mais il
a des soeurs partenaires et non la
question que l'on peut lui poser s'il
veut faire une saison 2 en quelque sorte
c'est de savoir s'il va nous proposer
une soeur une co partenaire c'est une
partenaire pour travailler à matignon la
voix la ram premier ministre savait que
quand même intéressante ou les
maquereaux nist vous dit ça ne peut être
qu'une femme s'il est réélu à l'elysée
tous le disent on verra la pression car
il avait senti vous l'avez senti les
signes en politique merci infiniment
vous savez d'informer marielle d'aragon
vous savez que le nom de la femme comme
apprendre à nommer ou ne sais pas encore
c'est ça la question
c'est une rumeur d'elisabeth bornes mais
rien n'est moins sûr allez merci à vous
merci marc crépon merci stéphane merci
mariette à demain très belle soirée
documentaire sur lcp tout de suite c'est
une série sur l' affaire madoff arnaque
en col blanc très belle soirée
[Musique]